well new here at 11 residents at a
Senior Living Apartment Complex in the
East Valley fear for their safety
tonight after a string of thefts and
vandalism at their property in fact last
night alone more than two dozen cars had
their tires slashed so residents
contacted police and the apartment
management team but still feel like
nothing is being done Madison Kimbrough
live right in that area near Pecos and
Russell with the story
dozens of cars damaged as you can see
with this car their tires have been
slashed you can see both of these right
here and as we talked to several people
who live here they say this isn't the
first time they've been victims of a
crime
no security no cameras break-ins car
stolen cars vandalized uh name it we've
had it Jeannie Reigns is just one of
many residents at Los Pecos senior
apartments who fears for their safety on
a daily basis Monday morning her
neighbor Karen Hoffman was on her way to
work when I walk out and I'm like I
guess I'm not going anywhere I've got a
flat tire
then I see the two vehicles leaning
on both sides of my car
both of them had two tires that were
slashed I took it upon myself
to walk around see how many
I counted 29 on the whole property and
that's not all within the last week
three people had their catalytic
converter stolen with several others
having their cars stolen all together
like Victoria Martinez who like the rest
of her neighbors is on a fixed income
and even struggles to pay rent due to
recent rent hikes I came out in the
morning the car was gone they broke the
door they broke the the ignition and
they messed it up inside so they gave me
a rental Meanwhile my rental was that I
was Lush this morning so I couldn't even
use it this morning and when it comes to
getting help everyone agrees the
management team doesn't seem to care we
tried contacting them today but because
of the holiday the management office was
closed we all called corporate that fell
on deaf ears you go in there and they
say yes we'll deal with it or they don't
even listen as for apartment security
they've asked repeatedly to Beef It Up
but are told it's too expensive if we
get security cameras door
and outside
that can help to cut somebody we need
lies more lies because on the other side
of the building it's only one lie and
everything is done keep this
for the vandalite cars vandalized cars
many had to call AAA or find other
resources while they wait to get their
tires fixed reporting near Pecos and
Russell Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now